hello everyone welcome back to the third
iteration of a weekly gaming news kind
of catch-up that i'm doing where i'm
specifically trying to cover gaming news
stories that i feel very positively
about
i'm also going to catch you all up on
last week's news story which was the
near automata
uh
unfathomable never before seen room
situation we did get an update like the
day after i posted that video but first
for this story
definitely a good one and also just kind
of a funny turn of events um so this is
from
videogameschronicle.com and it says ea
says single-player games are a really
important part of its portfolio but very
reliable live services are expected to
continue to dominate sales now
i imagine that this is at least
in part to
one of the worst tweets ever
um
this is my tweet about their tweet where
ea on june 30th tweeted there are ten
but they only like playing single-player
games if you are unfamiliar
with this meme
um the idea is saying someone is a 10
out of 10 but they have a fatal flaw
that's kind of just the idea you just
say a sentence
i memed this by saying something like
they're a 10 but they say
could care less when they mean couldn't
care less it's like something that like
would take someone off of being
perfect and it's it's a silly joke i
don't think that um
some of the responses to this were
necessary like there were people who
seemed really offended by
ea's tweet in ways that i found to be a
little bit extreme
i definitely think the studio heads uh
who responded who are making
single-player games like vince sampela
for example head of respawn
uh working on jedi fallen order 2 i
imagine
uh responded to this um for every studio
under ea that's working on
a single player game i get their
negative responses i get andy's joke
here delete this and then reboot anthem
into a single player rpg that would have
been nice
i love yakuza um
oh i wonder what the hidden tweets are
wow okay not that much uh
it's a joke i don't think it was worth
some of the outrage but i did quote
tweet it and say this may be one of the
worst brand tweets i've ever read which
i'm inclined to agree with um and stand
by because
it is such
a silly thing for a brand that makes
that product to tweet
especially a brand where people love
their single-player games
like for the insulin gaming community
it's their saving grace that dragon age
was so good that mass effect was so good
legendary edition just came out mirror's
edge hey kane is of amalor um
ea actually does have a really good
catalog i mean even dead space of
previously of single-player games that
either got worse or that they stopped
supporting uh so for them especially
it's just
it's just not a good tweet it's just not
a good tweet um
but they actually responded to it really
well i wonder how easy it will be for me
to find their response give me a second
which i guess sorry first for context
they had to because of how badly they
got roasted
they really um
it just really really really got torn
apart then you came to tender when you
don't know how to be attended
10 to use this character oof so i think
this was the
the main tweet um but also there is a
screenshot of vince's reply here you go
vince impeller
with the face palm so here was their
update they said i think it was same day
i believe or maybe a day oh 18 hours so
it was the same day roswell deserves
we'll take this l because playing single
player games actually makes them at 11.
i think this is a very good response
because they took the joke
there was a meme tweet anyway it wasn't
something that they intended to be
serious as kind of insensitive and just
terrible for their brand as it was
and then responded in the same kind of
language
and were like yeah okay you guys are
right i feel like a formal apology with
like the screenshot of the note stock
would have been silly um
i feel like doubling down on it would
have been silly i don't know it was just
they dealt with it they acknowledged
that they moved on it just it seemed
like a good uh a good response in my
opinion um i know you're not supposed to
say anything
positive about uh ea but uh
i felt like it was a succinct response
so to continue on this article
electronic arts has said that
single-player games are a really really
important part of its overall product
mix and i really hope that they believe
that
uh after appearing to actively shift
away from making single-player games
during the 2010s the company is
seemingly warmed to them again following
the success of star wars jedi fallen
order which um
is a game i enjoyed pretty well i think
the first episode of play watch listen
is about it it's like there's a lot of
very good stuff in it especially for the
first game like that that respawn had
made it's especially impressive i'm very
excited about the second one because it
felt like one of those games where the
first one was really solid and you're
like i bet you the second they'll nail
all of these concepts that they had to
just do fresh brand new for the first
time
uh single player games in development at
ea include star wars jedi survivor
dragon age red wolf and a dead space
remake if you count the dead space
remake i guess
move this over here
during its first quarter earnings call
on tuesday ea was asked how
single-player games currently fit into
the company's portfolio
our players on balance they have these
core motivations inspiration escape
social connection competition
self-improvement creation these things
that bring us together as players of
games said ea ceo andrew wilson actually
let me do my andrew wilson voice he's
australian and the creation of worlds
the building of characters and the
telling of stories is really important
in the fulfillment of some of those
motivations
when we think about our portfolio and we
think about building it out we really
think about it on two key vectors one
how can we tell incredible stories and
two how can we build tremendous online
communities and how do we bring those
two things together it's this seems like
such a strange
disingenuous answer on an ea earnings
call
when we think about our portfolio we
think about building out we really think
about two key vectors one how can we
tell incredible stories to how can we
build tremendous online communities and
then how do we bring those two things
together i mean i guess that's true what
you actually mean there is how can we
monetize the [ __ ] out of them
you just didn't say it that way
so when you look at our portfolio what
you should be looking for is how are we
doing that how are we building these
worlds and telling these stories i guess
they tried to with anthem that would be
an intended marriage of those two things
that clearly failed that i really hope
they've learned a lesson from of like
there was a lot of hype for that game i
was excited for that game when i first
played it it felt awesome and it fell
apart on launch
and um
it really feels like one of those things
where it's like you should have just let
it be what the team clearly wanted it to
be especially considering their
background rather than this
multiplayer online focused games as
service experience i think that's what
tanked anthem more than anything was
probably that publisher pressure i could
be completely wrong of course the studio
could have advocated for that from the
start but i'm inclined to doubt that
um how are we building these worlds and
telling these stories how are we
developing global online communities
before
uh not on fever anymore and how are we
bringing those two things together for
the fulfillment of motivations wilson
continued
and what we see when we get that is one
we grow our network and two we grow the
amount of time that players in our
network spend in and around our games
and that is the thing i've spoken about
a lot on the channel before but very
consistent across earnings calls or
shareholder calls that what the games
industry is very much focused on right
now is trying to um increase player
retention in individual games which is
why you're seeing games as service more
often so they're trying to actually sell
you less games overall but increase the
amount of time you spend in one game
that is
pretty consistent a lot of the aaa or
the third party aaa publishers
is they would prefer to release less
video games and just have you spend more
time in individual games and i think the
free to play model is almost appealing
because instead of just selling you
games and previously having to rely on
you know six
60 to 120 sales depending on what
country you're in shout out to australia
i'm pretty sure games are still a
hundred dollars there
um
which you know they can't reliably do
these days when so many things online
are competing for your attention
they want to monetize the hours you play
so they want to make it so that
one of the activision earnings calls
specifically listed that they felt video
games should be as profitable per
hour of entertainment consumed by the
consumer
uh as films which is say you go see a
movie it's 15 for an hour and a half
that's how much they want you to spend
on games
and that's certainly got to be a
challenge because i do not see myself
doing that i think that's part of why a
lot of publishers threw themselves at
nfts it was easy profit and not a lot of
uh time requirement um they're really
hoping that that could just become this
huge thing carried by
wales and um smaller consumers as well
but i don't know about that but that's
definitely definitely a goal um so
making single-player games
monetizable is obviously part of that
strategy
but uh
in in their case
so so much of what they end up talking
about is is just
how to
monetize player time or consume more
player type that is a very very big
thing is time we want all of your
goddamn time because
video games in some cases from a
publisher's perspective at least from
the money-making side of a publisher
could also be competing with streaming
services
um
looking at where motivations may or may
not be fulfilled is them talking about
competitors pretty directly i think like
they're like well we need to make sure
that we have every kind of gamer playing
our games all the time and maybe that
pushes them into more story focused
games games like god of war
uh that clearly appeal to players and
players will put a lot of time into uh
we'll look to supplement that with the
addition of new online games new
multiplayer games and new single-player
games you'll love to see it
however ea's chief financial officer
chris followed up by noting that live
services account for almost three
quarters of ea's total business which is
true and
nuts live service games make ea so much
money and i have been vocal about
thinking fifa ultimate team was so bad
for the industry because it was so good
for ea like when
people have these conversations where
they're like oh
this game made this much money the
publisher should be happy with that
based on projections they're never happy
because it's always being compared to
ultimate team which is so well monetized
again based on the hours
versus the actual uh money from players
it's just everyone wants to be ultimate
team and nobody will be will feel good
enough until they are ultimate team
it's rough
uh
chris followed up by saying if we think
about the model impact and financial
impact of it i think the first thing to
always keep in mind is that live
services still encompass on a trailing
12-month basis over 70 percent of our
business
that has been proven very reliable
highly recurring revenue stream which by
the way
generally is also an easy revenue stream
ultimate team because you just have an
artist make that thing once and then it
can be sold
you know limitless times um
and also all of the advertising for
ultimate team exists in ultimate team
you have to pay for that space it's just
it's
it's cheap for the teams compared to a
lot of different uh other sources of
revenue
uh that will still be predominant driver
in our profit and loss long term which
is not going anywhere that's
that's what the players have created in
this case second we talked a lot about
the areas of investment that we're
making and that's both in the live
service as well as some of the
single-player title launches that you've
seen
no thanks and so over the course of time
we'll continue to invest our long-term
growth will continue to invest in the
ongoing stable performance of our live
service businesses and services business
sorry and there'll be some puts putts
and takes along the way never heard that
phrase before
last week it was claimed that ea is
making a single player open while black
panther game which sounds awesome i
think this is just a rumor though title
is reportedly in early stages of
development and is likely being produced
at a recently established ea studio
headed
headed by former monolith productions
boss kevin stevens so
i'm glad they acknowledged this and i
think that um this phrasing here
that he
andrew wilson repeats about the
fulfillment of motivations is what i
find comforting
it's like
this board of people at ea who function
so differently to other parts of the
industry who are all hired as
businessmen not necessarily because they
have background in game development or
anything a lot of them have backgrounds
in business that's so
clear um i mean you can google it but
it's so clear in the way that they
function
if they're thinking about needing to
fulfill a lot of different motivations
for people to play games then they
recognize that there is a large desire
for story-based games
um
and that means that they are going to
feel like they need to compete in that
landscape to get again more of that
player time so that you aren't playing
some other third-party single-player
game so that you aren't playing god of
war so that you're playing something on
ea instead
or something ea owns instead and that
means that they have to make things that
are very very very good single-player
games so i really hope that this
business-y term fulfillment of
motivations actually leads to that
um not not definite news but they don't
have a reason to lie to
people on an earnings call about this
kind of thing this is obviously a thing
that most players would want to hear but
them saying it on a news call meaning it
means it's going to happen that they are
still having a focus on single-player
games so i really hope that this leads
to something good
it feels good like i said
ea used to make such
good games
um
which is probably part of the
frustration with like the direction that
they've had it in but they used to be so
so so so so good so i hope this is true
and it's definitely something that
really um
appeals to me or if i'm very comforting
about what sony is doing right now is
that
sony still makes a lot of its money from
third-party game sales on the
playstation store
um this is my perspective this is not
insider information
i don't get looped into anything
regarding this kind of thing at sony
this is just a perspective
a very consumer level perspective
but they make a lot of money from
third-party game sales on the
playstation so everything you buy on the
playstation store they get a cut 30 cut
and that's a lot of sales
so in order to make sure
that you still buy a playstation so you
get into that ecosystem
sony and i think nintendo both are still
extremely focused on making sure that
they have very good single player games
and i'm very comforted by that strategy
because it means
the single player games that come out on
a playstation console are of very very
very high quality they have a lot of
resources they have a lot of time
the dev teams have a lot of creative
control again just my perspective that
i'm removing myself professionally from
that entirely too
um
and that's awesome because it it means
that in order to make you buy a
playstation the games have to be really
really really really good
and they know that as a business
strategy that that's kind of reflected
in ea here again with the fulfillment of
motivations um i think game passes is
has made xbox's strategy a little bit
different not to say that i don't think
a lot of xbox exclusives are very good i
love psychonauts too i'm really excited
about fable i mean uh there's no doubt
that that starfield is gonna you know
help them ship consoles but the game
pass focus to me makes it feel like
that's not necessarily guaranteed down
the line i think you're more likely to
get
which is the thing i like by the way
that i like the variety i think game
pass is more likely to lead to shorter
experiences certainly still lots that
will be
single player
certainly still a lot they'll be
extremely high in quality but i actually
think you're more likely to get games
like stray
on game pass down the line
then you are to get like a big
blockbuster game like your last of us
part two super expensive
longer um
and again i'm actually happy to have
both of those distinctions i'm happy to
have those two different camps and said
there are a lot of really long
junky games on game pass too in any case
i'm glad to hear this there are facets
of the games industry that i feel
positively about
this is your positive news story of the
week um
happy to hear them acknowledge it and
and hope that you know they keep a focus
on on
letting
the team at respawn make the best jedi
fall in order
or two i guess it's not called that i
just keep forgetting survivor we're
gonna just call it jedi fall in order to
for a while the best version of that
possible
uh so for the second part of this video
i just wanted to update everybody on
last year sorry last week's
near automata thing it was unfortunately
a mod which i'm joe really nailed this
here modding isn't as impossible as we
thought and it's a bright new future for
the community um
it was a mod that was just so impressive
that nobody thought it could be done
which i you know i wanted it to be this
wholesome kid who found something
that they didn't know how to help their
friend into i wanted that so bad but i
think
new modding tools existing that are like
this impressive
also pretty cool and the way it went
down
i thought it was fun i'm glad it wasn't
marketing um
so the article from ign here says
excuse me
after days of intrigue
it's finally been revealed that the
mysterious work videos of hit
hurto unknown areas in neo automata were
the work of extremely talented modders
yeah there were several of them the
church saga began when i read a user
called sad futago posted a video of a
door that no near player had ever seen
before and followed it up with clips
that showed bizarre content that
included references to other games
um that was after i had posted i think
that it included some references to
drakengard i believe
it is hooked the near community and many
others who couldn't work out if this was
an arg for a new game or the work of
modders although the latter had been
deemed impossible by many and i just
believed them
i have like friends who are like high up
in the modding community
and i believed them um
but this is the
i guess the live chat of them
just actually streaming it ah it's very
cool as it turns out it wasn't as
impossible to mod near automata as we
thought with the twitch stream revealing
that the entire saga was indeed the work
of talented fans creating new content
within the game as you can see in the
gallery below the twitch stream ended
with an admission that all of this was
created with mods by three individuals
called
devilis revenge
woeful wolf and raider b who i think
what makes it cooler is that they also
had the smarts
to think ahead with the way those reddit
posts are constructed
i i just i really like this story
uh thank you reads a text slide that add
at the end of the stream everything we
have shared has been completely in
in-game no editing was used we've been
loving all the discussions and theories
it has been an amazing journey it has
been inspiring to see the community come
together after so many years it has made
all the hard work well worth it
and then they have some quotes here so
devilis uh designed the map and said
thanks everyone for sticking along for
the ride whether you expected this
outcome or not i hope you enjoyed the
impact it was never meant to blow up
this big but just to confuse a few
people on twitter this would absolutely
this would be absolutely impossible in
any form without woeful and rated b and
then woeful said it has been quite a few
years now when i started this i never
thought we would ever get this far i
simply wanted to fix the lunatia model
thank you everyone everything has been
so motivational thank you devilis
revenge for being such a great friend
thank you ready for joining the team you
took things to eleven and then reader b
who did scripting tools
said it's been an honor what oh you
australian it's been an honor working on
this and to be a part of this crew i've
had lots of fun and i'm excited to see
where this goes in the future by the way
check out photon reddit.com glory to
modding kind good reference
i just even their response is so nice i
still feel good about the story
i still feel good about the story
uh ign went on to say while some will be
disappointed that this doesn't mean
official near content is coming soon the
fact that the team has been
team has begin adding in-game content to
automata at all is huge news for the
community many believe this wasn't
possible but the modders have promised
to release new blender add-ons and
scripting tools on an open source basis
which you also love to see seemingly
blowing the modding scene wide open for
the first time
it's awesome uh the church scene itself
will be released let everyone play what
they've been watching and the team says
they have so much more in store
including an already finished mod from
raider b ah they apologize they wanted
to give off the impression of this being
secret or cut content not a full-blown
arg which i think they did they also
said they weren't trying to impersonate
near creator yokotaro who has been drawn
into the mystery over the last few days
and who would subsequently be praised
for not ruining the mystery that's a
good point he tweeted
and said something
vague about it but he didn't ruin it he
didn't say it wasn't that he really like
it must have been fun for that team to
watch
um then they said finally the team
apologized for the anticlimactic ending
saying they were running out of time to
do it due to personal reasons which is
totally fair
however much of the community has been
celebrating the reveal for breathing
life into the community even before mods
are released
i think that this rules it's cool that
they're releasing the mods and i love
that it came from a nice team even if it
wasn't the wholesome
kid
that we expected it seems like it's
still people who were just like really
humbled by this experience it was fun
for a lot of people and it means more
mods are coming for that game so
i still feel really really good about it
this has been your positive gaming news
for the week everybody i will see you
next wednesday or thursday i think i'm
planning to publish these
um so i'll see you then